get the court see as it's fair for a
woman to get this like we're saying
about the West the reason that this is a
law is because the courts have decided
not women that it's fair for women
especially where they couldn't maybe
have an income
no but the context is the court is a
business it makes money men pay into the
court system
and then women claim legal aid which is
taxpayers money which men are the
taxpayers because they're working right
then what happens is is basically women
get half of the man's money because he's
working he has to pay the legal fees he
has to pay child support which also goes
to the woman and then there's a level of
entitlement that